it's a contradiction City over Biden's
docu drama the Secret Service is ready
to turn over who visited the president's
Delaware home if requested by Congress
but wait the White House said those
visitor logs didn't exist sounds like a
good question to ask karinge Jean-Pierre
but we all know that's a Fool's errand I
already answered your question go ahead
well I I did no you didn't well it's
your it's your opinion I'm having a hard
time understanding why I just said
questions about we shall seizure and I
just said and I just said to you the
White House council's office will be
able to address that question from this
on are you not going to be taking
questions about the classified doctor I
have been very clear over and over again
we are going to be prudent again that's
for the Department why is it a deal and
let's be clear it's not your decision to
make of what I can or can't answer from
here let's be clear so you can see why
the White House reporters have had
enough of Jean-Pierre according to a new
report members have grown exasperated
and call her briefings a painful waste
of time all this comes as Jesse Waters
gets his hands on some spicy new Hunter
Biden photos showing the disgrace first
son cruising around in Joe's prize
Corvette just outside the garage and
Jesse if you notice he's driving with
the blurs do you know the blurs they're
a family of blurred people that was his
niece and her friend and by the way they
were dressed it looked like they're
going to the beach and this was right
around the time he was cutting a deal
with the Chinese for six million dollars
to the Biden family and right around the
time that these documents were in the
garage I don't know if you left the
garage door open close I don't know if
Hunter was the one that moved the boxes
of documents into the garage and if he
had any help moving those in but we have
no idea the thing was at this time he
had no secret service detail between the
time he was VP and by the time he was
the nominee so who knows who was in and
out of the garage now they say they
don't really have records of these logs
from the president's private residence
bongino says you know they might have a
record of the pool or the pizza guy that
comes in but if like Paulie P comes over
to watch the game and talk stocks with
Hunter they're not going to jot his name
down remember Bill Clinton and Chappaqua
when Hillary would leave for LaGuardia
and five minutes later the mistress
would show up the code named her the
Energizer Bunny she was not on any
visitor log for a private residence but
we'll see how it shakes out all right
excellent excellent reporting thank you
very much yeah watch some more spicy
photos tonight at seven exactly you know
uh Jessica you said that uh in the break
that you're fed up with Corrine
Jean-Pierre why are you such a racist
homophobe
oh great
um
cringe I wasn't expecting because that
wasn't in the telepromise
um is this being handled poorly yeah it
from a communication standpoint if you
say it's a doj problem then you demand
that a doj spokesperson show up and tell
everybody there will be no comment until
X time when we have more information or
something can leak out from the special
counsel but this is something that is
really upsetting to Democrats first of
all that he had them when he wasn't
supposed to have them but that we have
no idea about the timeline of all of
this and it's not something that I
believe still is comparable to what went
on with former president Trump because
he had to be stalked to get these
documents back and you know Jay Brad had
to show up at Mar-A-Lago to have a
conversation with them because they said
we returned everything and they hadn't
done it and it seems that the Biden
Administration is cooperating but you
have to make those details clear so that
people who are your supporters can
continue to have faith in the fact that
you did handle this as responsibly as
possible no one thinks that there aren't
former officials that have class
certified documents in bad places stuff
happens like you move out of offices
things and you should return them when
you figure that out but by just
stonewalling and saying I can't answer
that I'm not going to answer that then
you leave people to their wildest
imaginations and it's not great
especially when he's supposed to
announce that he's running for
reelection again in a couple of weeks
there you go judge is this gonna is this
the effect the deliberate effect from
the Democrats to keep him from launching
well I think I said this last week I
said you know what this could be the
Democrats saying we got to get this
Geezer out of the way but I have to
respond Jessica to what you said only
because you said it was so much worse
than Trump here's the difference between
Trump and Biden Trump could declassify
Biden could not Biden had the records
for six years they were from the Obama
White House okay and Biden had them in a
place paid for by the Chinese 50 million
dollars okay in addition to that Biden
was not honest with the Amer American
people they knew on November 2nd that
they had classified documents found by
lawyers who are parently at nighttime
moving men with no clearance and then
they found stuff on December 20th but
when they told us about it on January
9th they weren't honest about the fact
that they also had stuff from December
20th so I don't think it's a question of
them handling it poorly I think it's a
question of them answer handling it
dishonestly and I'll tell you another
thing I think Kareem Jean-Pierre if she
had any respect for herself in her own
career she would say do not send me out
in front of the American public looking
like I'm covering up like I'm lying or
I'm an idiot you either tell me or you
give me someone to refer them to and
that
hold on one second hold that thought
Dana this leads me to my big million
dollar question you know the Press
secretaries are a very small Club female
press secretary's even smaller literally
because they're they weigh less yeah has
has Korean ever reached out to you to
say hey I need some help you're really
good at this no I'm sure and look she's
got a lot of friends and supporters I'm
sure she could call any of them any
member of the their group for example
like Jen Saki but what the judge just
said I think is very very correct so
Biden and Klein have allowed this woman
to go out there one they either didn't
tell her
and when she I believe her when she said
she didn't know she found out the same
day the Press Corps did so it looks like
she was involved in a cover-up if she
did know but she didn't know so then
they're like oh wait so you don't know
what you're talking about so you don't
have the confidence of the chief of
staff and they just sit there and let
her twist in the wind every single day
and by the way where is Kamala Harris
where help a sister out if I were
calling Harris I would go into the chief
of staff's office into Biden and say
tomorrow somebody from the justice
department is going to help her out and
they're going to walk through this
timeline oh you are ruining her ability
to have a command in that room and when
you have White House reporters start to
talk to the Press about how the unhappy
they are it's very hard to dig out of
that you know those you know what a like
a construction site it'll say 80 days
without a safety incident at the White
House they have zero days of providing
inaccurate information partly it's her
fault and that she has to make sure to
protect herself that's your number one
job because it's the only asset that you
have but the president himself and Ron
playing the chief of staff owe her
something better than what they have
provided because they are making her job
so much harder than it needs to be did
you want her last word Jessica or is it
already
has happened oh no it was about that
timeline of things and that Trump
there's no evidence that Trump
Declassified things but everyone
everyone knows that I feel that way and
the judge feels this way and I think
Dana makes a great point about them
offering some help I get it all right hi
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now